So, it's impossible really to put a number. Nobody can.
How much debt is too much debt?
If you look at Japan today, you see a country...
...where the debt-to-GDP ratio is something like 240 percent.
Well above, orders of magnitude above, where the US is today...
...or even where the US is forecast to be in the future.
And so, the question is: How is Japan able to sustain a debt of that size?
Wouldn't it have an inflation problem?
Wouldn't it lead to rising interest rates?
Wouldn't this be destructive in some way? And the answer to all of those questions...
...as Japan has demonstrated now for years is simply no.
Japan's debt is close to 240 percent of GDP, almost a quadrillion,...
...that's a very big number, yen.
Long-term interest rates are very close to zero.
There's no inflation problem and so, despite the size of the debt,...
...there are no negative consequences...
...as a result and I think Japan teaches us a really important lesson.